[Music]
let's go out to Kansas City and talk to
se T what's up
Scott thanks Dr John it's such an honor
to be on the show with you I'm grateful
for you man it's an honor for me what's
up all right here's what's up so here's
the question and then we'll Circle back
around for more context but should I
attend my dad's upcoming wedding even
though I believe he is not a healthy
person has no business getting married
and I feel sorry for his uh girlfriend
now fiance because internally I am
screaming why are you even marrying my
Dad
wow it sounds like there is a I'm
smiling because wow that's a lot dude
what' your dad
do what does he what did he do yeah what
what what brought your relationship
here uh that has been a very long
road um most
recently he and my mom separated about
two years ago and then got officially
divorced about this time last year and
then the ink was hardly dry on the
documents before he was telling me he
was out there looking for a
girlfriend
um growing up I have come to
realize he was emotionally and verbally
abusive um never physical but
emotionally verbally very controlling
and kind of like a roundabout
manipulative Sinister type of way you
just feel crushed like there's no power
there for
you um and also my mom would have dealt
with that and more too before they
separated so how old are you
now I am 28
okay um do you have contact with your
dad do y' all talk
regularly am I I do have contact he
lives in the area um I think over this
like this calendar year we may have
talked slash got them together for
family events one
two three four maybe five times so you
don't have a relationship with
them no okay okay so so so give me we do
this get why would you
go why would I go
yep because it feels like a very big
thing to
say I'm your son and I'm not going to
your wedding
did it feel like a big thing when he
said I'm your dad and I'm leaving your
mom and I'm going out on the playing
field to get lucky
again yeah did it feel like a big thing
when he
said I don't give a crap what you think
about X and Y and Z you need to do this
you should do this I can't believe you
did that you failed this and he's been
doing that to you your whole freaking
life yeah those are those are big things
so
at some point you're going to have to
decide I'm going to continue to prop up
my dad's emotional health for him
because he is too much of a coward to go
get the help he needs to be able to hold
himself
up and that's what you have done for him
his your whole your whole life and his
whole time of knowing
you
fair yep very
fair so I can't tell you whether to go
to this wedding or
not I am somewhat of a
peacekeeper so i' probably just go but I
wouldn't go for him I'd go for
me but also if you said dude I can't go
to this I can't be a part of this he
ditched my mom and he's already getting
remarried to' be a slap in the face to
my mom and more importantly I'm
not I'm not going to be his little Pat
me on the head approver boy
anymore like that's it's not my job he's
a grown
man and if he still needs his little
boy's approval to blow up the family and
to start a new family I'm that's not my
job anymore I'm not doing that anymore
if you said I'm not going I'd highfive
you for that
too but I don't want you to go out of
cowardice out of I don't want to make
him
mad right I don't want to hurt his
feelings because he hasn't given a crap
about your feelings
ever and it's probably fair to say in
times when he pretended to care about
your feelings it was because he couldn't
handle your bad feelings not because he
actually cared that you were hurting is
that
fair yeah I think that's there are a lot
of the times that come to my mind like I
think it was more like kind of like
damage control like here let me come fix
this issue with my son or let me work on
this issue because the result is
otherwise it would look bad for me right
um and so I don't want to hit my kid I
know he didn't hit you but I'm just
using that because it's an outlandish
example I don't want to hit my kid not
because it's wrong because I'm going to
hurt a child because I'm going to make
my child unable to understand what Love
Actually is feels like in a connected
deep resounding way but I'm not going to
hit my kid cuz I don't want people to
think I'm a bad
guy one of those is noble and honorable
and one of them is grossly
self-serving right yep
yeah so I think after when you live with
somebody like that you develop
um crippling
overthinking how' you
know because I've sat with people like
you for 20 years and you Loop and loop
and loop because here's why you've been
trying to please a boss who has
no um you've been trying to make a boss
happy without a job
description and on Monday you sell five
things and your boss is like that's
amazing and then Tuesday you sell five
things and he's like you suck you should
have sold 15 and Wednesday you knock on
his door to tell him you sold five
things and he does even answer
it and so what you develop is this
spinning thought wheel for lack of
better terms and there's some actual
biochemical processes going on here but
you develop a maniacal spinning thought
wheel trying to figure out the way you
can bridge the gap to his
heart because what happens with little
boys especially but happens with little
girls too is when you have a father like
you had and let's be honest he provided
food do you have shelter
yes right so there is there is a good
side to this you learned some stuff and
my guess is you've probably become very
sophisticated in how you manage
workplace politics is that
fair uh it depends maybe
okay
so youve been trying to answer the
question your whole life like Dad do you
love me what is it why why why do we
keep having to why can't you
just and I tell you this wedding isn't
going to solve
that no it it's not going to end me and
my siblings are just waiting for when
it's going to blow up again well it's I
I wouldn't wait I'd go on with my
life and you see what I'm saying like
y'all are waiting for the explosion
you've been waiting for this explosion
your whole lives and it always comes but
what you do is you don't live your life
for 19 months at a time because you're
got your breath
held and you let stupid crass evil
things be said at the five Gatherings
you get together every year and you he
shows up late or shows up drunk or shows
up like this or talks to your mom like
that and she goes it's fine guys it's
fine and you hold your breath and then
it BL blows up and then it all exhales
and what you realize is oh holding my
breath for 19 months or 24 months or 2
years or 3 years whatever didn't prevent
this and so I'll tell you you and your
siblings should just as the great Jay-Z
said brush your shoulders off and move
on go live your
life and when it blows up which we all
know it will and your dad calls blaming
her for this what you can say yeah dad
of course we all I mean what do you want
me to say we all saw this coming you
know what I mean but you will have been
so much further down the road than you
just pulling off the side of the road
with a door open and your blinkers on
waiting for him to blow up his life so
he can come back and get back in your
car because that's not your
job
right so what I'm saying sounds mean but
I also hope you hear it as
empowering yeah no I hear it that way
that's definitely something that as I've
worked on this in therapy for the last
year or two like coming around to the
realization that like no like it is
boundaries and it does feel mean it
looks mean but it's it's boundaries it's
keeping me safe and letting him just
live his life and yeah and here here's
here's the big question has he asked
your opinion on on any of
this he has one time asked me about what
he think what I think about his
relationship with his
girlfriend what' you
say I told him that I thought he was
moving too fast that this wasn't a good
idea that I think he needed to work on
himself more and if behavior is a
language what did he say back to
you he said he doesn't care
booya that's talking
about he asked your opinion and when you
didn't validate
him he said I don't want anything to do
with you you're
wrong so he took your your wisdom which
is incredibly wise and he took your your
thoughts and your thinking and your care
and love for
him and he used it as toilet
paper that's it
and so he's not coming back to you and
saying hey like for real though like is
this a good idea because I won't do it
if you guys think this is too fast I
feel like um me and your mom we were
separate for a we lived in the same
house but we've been apart for 10 years
and I feel alive
again is this too fast and y'all go yeah
Dad you're not
okay and he goes all right dude I'm
gonna go talk to
somebody yeah man I would hold that
dude's hand I'd I'd ride to the end of
Earth with that
guy but but the guy that just goes
around to his children trying to get
them to Pat him on the back for how
great he is when he's just destroyed
your our mom's life and
um he's trying to drag us along with him
into the future I'm I don't know I'm not
gonna play so after more talking I I
take back my earlier thing that I'd
probably just go I probably wouldn't
go I would though and this is just me um
I'm a pretty direct I don't say
confrontational but like I'll just don't
mind having hard conversations I'd
probably sit down with them and say Hey
Dad I I've thought about it over and
over again I can't I'm not going to I'm
not going to go to your wedding what
yeah Dad it doesn't feel right to me
feels very very quick um I feel like you
got a lot of healing that needs to
happen and this feels fast and so I'm
gonna sit this one out you can tell them
I'm G sit this one out I'll catch the
next one that'd be a great joke but
um all I have to say man um all jokes
aside I'm heartbroken for you this is
isn't how it's supposed to
be and you've probably held your mother
she's wept over last year and it's not
how it's supposed to be and you've
probably uncovered some things in
therapy that about how your dad treated
you and let's be honest about how your
mom just stood by and watched some of it
happen which is scary too and
frustrating and traumatic
also and it's not supposed to be that
way I'm sorry my friend but here's the
deal I can't answer this for you I can
just tell you what I would do um
I don't think you lose either way
whether you go or whether you skip it
the only way you lose is if you make a
decision out of fear or out of pandering
or out of
cowardice I'm gonna go because I don't
want him to get mad at me again then
you've lost not because you went or not
because you didn't go because once again
you gave him the keys to your life it's
time for you to take back your own life
thanks for the call my
brother